alex honor is a superstar in the world
of professional rock climbing he's best
known as the first person to climb the 3
000 foot cliff at el capitan in yosemite
national park without any ropes it was
documented in the academy award-winning
free solo film now he is taking
filmmaking to a whole new level check
this out with a new virtual reality
movie called the soloist vr it shows him
climbing some of the world's most iconic
mountains what makes this so remarkable
is the stunning and i mean stunning
virtual reality that gives us a 360
degree view of these crimes alex honol
joins us right now from las vegas good
morning alex how are you doing wow good
good good morning guys
thank you for joining us now
you have done this before but it was
just a documentary this vr is something
special so what made you want to turn
your climbs into a virtual reality
experience
mostly i think the vr experience is a
pretty impressive way to share i mean
you guys got to see it it's just so much
more immersive than
conventional filmmaking and so it's a
cool way to be able to show what i love
about climbing with with people that i
care about you know my family gets to
see this and be like whoa that's what
it's actually all about yeah listen i
have to say alex whoa that's what it's
all about is right i felt like i was on
your back at certain points a couple of
times i know i'm still standing on
ground somebody had to hold me up
because i thought i was going to fall
into the abyss stomach was uneasy knees
got away it wasn't easy it's amazing it
really is it really is i can't say
enough about it what are you hoping
people will get out of it maybe you want
the reaction that i'm talking about
because it was like nothing i've ever
seen or felt
yeah i think i think that's part of it
for sure what i'm hoping that people
take from it is a sense of the the joy
that i get from free souling because
typically when people ask me about
climbing without a rope they're asking
about the risk of death and the danger
and those kinds of things they rarely
ask about the beauty of it and the the
positive side of the experience and i
feel like with the vr filmmaking
experience you can look around you can
see the birds you can see the view you
can enjoy the mountains behind you and
so
you know you get to experience some of
the positive sides of sowing like the
reasons that i love going into the
mountains
yeah alex it's tony here i mean i think
people need to understand at home that
what's so special about this documentary
is when you put on the headset you are
in essence the cameraman so the person
watching you can watch you or just take
in the mountain take in the sunset look
anywhere there is amazing moments when
i'm standing in the headset in your
kitchen
and you're talking with your wife yeah
if i get bored with the conversation i
can like wander over and look in your
cabinets it's wild stuff but you
wouldn't get bored of conversation with
the wife yeah no no i'm not saying
anything about that
i felt like a voyer i was like an
invisible man it's really incredible
it's hard to explain to somebody who's
not in it and we got we got them here i
really do feel like it's a breakthrough
i wonder for you alex since you do so
much training before you climb and
thinking about the roots does vr hold
the potential to maybe be a replacement
for actually physically going out at
times and getting that climbing buzz or
experience
i don't think that vr will ever be a
substitute for the actual uh sort of
body awareness of the movement of
climbing because you have to practice
the movement to really be able to do it
but i do think the vr can definitely
prepare you for a place you know it's
like by looking around and appreciating
the mountains it can take some of the
the newness out of going to a new
setting i mean for me watching the vr
film you know i watched the dolomites
and i was only there briefly while we
were filming this and i can look around
and look at the mountains and when i go
back to the dolomites it's gonna feel
familiar to me because i've now spent so
much time watching it you know in vr i
don't know i mean there is
i don't know there's interesting
opportunities with vr for sure
alex there are so many things about you
that impress me the preparation like
tony talked about um but one thing that
i kept thinking about is the
fearlessness that you approach these
climbs with i have to ask are you afraid
of anything do you have any phobias
yeah
maybe not phobias at this point but no
i'm definitely afraid of things just
like anybody else but the things that
you're seeing in the vr film are all
things that i've practiced for things
that i've trained for for a very long
time
you know it's
it makes sense to not be too afraid of
them because that's that's what i've
spent 25 years getting ready for
you have a new baby in the house a new
baby girl has it changed your risk
tolerance
for with baby june
yeah so far it hasn't changed too much
except that i'm much sleepier but uh
okay yeah tony can identify with that i
can definitely but i'm not upside down
on a rock right sometimes you feel like
it but alex ronald thank you so much for
joining us the soloist vr is available
today on oculus tv please go check it
out yeah it's worth it